So how do you do? The correct answer is that the GCF is 9qp squared, and the
remaining factors are 3qp minus 2q plus 5p. Let's see how we got that answer.
First I want to look at the numbers 27, 18, and 45. So I ask myself, what is the
largest number that goes evenly into 27, 18, and 45? And with some practice
you'll notice that the largest number that goes into those three numbers is 9.
When we look at the variables, I need the variable to be in each of the 3 terms
and I want to take the lowest exponent of each of the variables. So for the q's,
I have q squared, q squared, and q. So the lowest exponent is 1. For the p's I
have p cubed, p squared, and p cubed, so the lowest power of p is squared. So
the GCF as we said was 9qp squared. What I'm trying to figure out what are the
remaining factors, I want to look at the first term, 27 q squared p cubed and I
want to ask myself, what do I need to multiply the GCF by to get the first term.
First you'll look at the coefficient. I need to multiply 9 by 3 to get 27. I
have to multiply q by q to get q squared. And I need to multiply p squared by p
to get p cubed. So, that's the first term. For the next term, once again I ask
myself. What do I need to multiply the GCF by to get the second term? I need to
multiply 9 by 2 to get 18. I need to multiply q by q to get q squared. And what
do I need to multiply p squared by to get p squared? Nothing, just 1. So our
second term is 2q or negative 2q. And then I put the next sign, which is plus.
What do I need to multiply 9qp squared by to get the third term? Well, 9 times 5
is 45. Q times 1 is q. P squared times p gives me p cubed. When factoring, one
of the most important steps is to find and factor out the GCF. Let's get back to
Chris so he can teach us more about factoring.